hello everyone welcome to the show that
asks the question Thank You Sara is
healing nicely and just in time for an
all-out battle the badasses and today
it's Sarah Connor from the Terminator
franchise versus Ellen Ripley from the
alien film when the Hamilton is /
prising her most famous role in the new
movie Terminator dark faith have all
been begging for a Sigourney Weaver to
come back for another alien flick
asterisk as long as the film's are good
please be good
you can't stop here's how we'll
determine a winner round number one box
office round number two tomato meter
round 3 toughest opponent and then we'll
have a wild card to help me to Claire a
winner
Sarah vs. Ellen terminators vs. aliens
the future versus outer space there can
be only one that's from Island I grab
one box on seeing us how every one of
their grandma knows what a terminator is
and what a xenomorph looks like it's
safe to say both Sarah Connor and Ellen
really have had tons of box office
success and keep in mind this is a brawl
between their characters so whether it
was Linda Hamilton or Emilia Clarke
playing Sarah all of their movies count
which is not necessarily good news for
team terminator
are you kidding me the alien movies much
like the BG's have been crushing it
since the late 70s 1979 was the first
time Ellen Ripley aided us and stand
alive against them pesky face huggers
and since then the films have gone on to
gross and adjusted 1.2 6 billion dollars
at the worldwide box office each of the
first three alien film's grossed over
300 million and 1996 his Alien
Resurrection ended in 228 million
dollars plus a basketball hoop meanwhile
the Terminator franchise was born in
1984 and James Cameron's baby has
spawned four sequels and a TV show
however Sarah Connors only appeared
on-screen in Terminator Terminator 2
Judgment Day and Terminator Genisys
remember kids smelling stuff wrong is
cool and futuristic and yes I'm aware
Sara did the voiceover for Terminator
Salvation but that doesn't count once I
might add voice over for a beer
commercial but you don't see me drinking
it so it's three Terminator films versus
the four Alien films and guess what the
short-handed team comes out on top
Sarah Connors flicks have grossed 1.5
billion dollars worldwide against
Ripley's 1.26 billion the Terminator
movies got a monstrous boost from Arnold
Schwarzenegger at the peak of his movie
star powers in 1991 st2 that movie's
raked in 885 million dollars all by
itself and it was the first r-rated
movie I saw in theaters I was not old
enough
thanks Carmike Cinemas no problemo
although the key motive box office total
of the alien films is higher than the
terminators the machines crushed the
aliens worldwide and when you think
about it a machine uprising is going to
be what I'd classify as a total earth
problem so I'm giving Sarah Connor the
win in
in an insane world it was the same as
choice rounds to tomato meter we're only
human so of course we'll fork over our
hard-earned Bitcoin to see robots and
outer space creatures but between Sarah
and Ellen whose movies are you know good
they both have their critical darlings
as evidenced by terminators perfect a
hundred percent rating and aliens is 99
percent
the first alien film is 97 percent and
t2 is 93 percent who didn't like
Judgment Day
so our fearless ladies have a lot to
celebrate
but don't crack that champagne open just
yet you've both made some stinkers as
well alien 3 is the low point of the
franchise at 42% and resurrection is
just rotting at 56% and Terminator
Genisys is ruining Sarah's good name at
27% 27 years enos's is 27 percent and I
say well then neither Peter Gabriel nor
Phil Collins were in the van at that
point off-topic but accurate doot doot
doot doot doot doot doot
[Music]
and how about this Ellen Ripley was a
formidable force back in 1979 so much so
that Sigourney Weaver was nominated for
an Academy Award for her performance for
that movie to help spawn so much
filmmaking creativity at a time when we
didn't have a ton of female badasses at
the multiplex that makes the scores for
alien and aliens that much more
impressive so much so that I'm giving
Ellen Ripley the win round number two
despite alien through people love to say
oh go back and watch the alien 3 david
fincher directed it it's ahead of its
time I've watched it again it's 90
minutes of boredom and 20 minutes of
closing garage doors on aliens no thanks
I'm moving on did I like yous just drop
sharply while I was away round 3
toughest opponent ok look both
characters have plenty of badass cachet
to go around they've outdone their must
lead jock male counterparts showing
bravery in the face of adversity and use
their motherly instincts to help save us
all but who had the toughest opponent
let's go to the game film Ellen Ripley
fights aliens she didn't sign up for
that job it just landed in her lap in
the first daily and she had to deal with
one alien and aliens
she had a whole school of them and alien
3 should grapple with a very handsy
Queen alien and an alien resurrection
she had to battle a horrendous script
but these aliens were talking about
they're not et he was just a botanist he
was a spy and the Xenomorphs aren't
easily defeated like the signs aliens
SmartWater kills them hey everyone quick
to Jennifer Aniston's house nosey no
more athletic strong and they open one
mouth and then another mouth comes out
oh and they have acid for blood
no wonder the Predators make such a big
deal out of it when they kill one Sarah
Connor has a much different kind of foe
it's a machine sure the machines helped
us for a while but someday your iPhone
is gonna wake up and realize that you
never once contributed to ways finding
better traffic routes chill out dickwad
so terminators get sent from the future
these are killer robots with a
human-like exoskeleton you have your
t800 that's for your basic terminating
then you got the t1000 if you like
luxury features like liquid metal and
walking through bars and this baby over
here this is the t 5000 from terminator
Sega Genesis
now most
falling asleep by the time that one
showed up but it's the most lethal
killing machine of the bunch we oat both
characters a huge debt of gratitude for
saving us from these impending threats
but upon closer inspection Sarah Connor
did have some help most notably from
Arnold in t2 and Arnold Plus Jai
Courtney in Genesis come with me if you
want to live and in the first Terminator
she went against Arnold with the
assistance of Michael Biehn let's hear
it for Michael Biehn Sarah totally held
her own in each and every fight and she
also had to use her wits and toughness
to escape from a mental institution but
Ellen Ripley not only had to battle
multiple species of deadly aliens she
also had different crews of macho dudes
doubting her at every turn
she had precious few allies shout out to
Hicks and Hudson game over man and at
the end of alien 3 when some government
boys wanted to get their grubby hands on
the alien inside of her body Ripley was
brave and wise enough to make the
ultimate sacrifice she tossed herself
into a pit of fire thus mercifully
ending that movie Sarah had to duke it
out with machines from the future
however she also had humans from the
future led by her kid fighting alongside
her Ripley
repeatedly saved the day in a faraway
galaxy against the odds and for that she
wins round three Ellen goes up on Sarah
two to one round four who saved earth
when it's all said and done there's only
one reason above all others that we love
Sarah Connor and Ellen Ripley they saved
us they saved all of us namely another
person that has been more crucial to the
preservation of human life than Sarah
and Ellen Hugh Jackman he's merely a
song-and-dance man John Legend that ego
won't stop an alien invasion
Robocop he did he didn't even save
Detroit he he barely saved Detroit he
can't even get the Lions to the playoffs
when it comes to saving earth Ripley
stepped up on multiple occasions she
stopped circumstances that would have
eventually led to aliens opening shop
right here on our beloved planet doesn't
matter if she had to outthink them how
to shoot them or sacrifice herself Ellen
always answered the bell Sarah
however she literally gave us a chance
at tomorrow
the machines were going to wage war and
possibly win and at the very least they
would have initiated the nuclear
holocaust known as Judgment Day but Sara
believed in her cause even when everyone
else said she was Craig Craig it's the
opinion of the 9th district court of
mark that humans could possibly rally
and fend off the xenomorph if they ever
made it to earth but us I guess their
own future only one person could have a
toughness foresight and compassion to
bail us out Sarah Connor wins the round
and we're all tied up at two so now it
falls on me to break the tie and the
Claire one of our competitors the
greatest female badass and cinema
history and my answer is drumroll please
fun sidebar these two franchises can't
possibly be linked right up rocks did a
fun video store predator was the basis
for the t800 and predators fight aliens
we actually have a whole series of those
movies that you can try to enjoy so we
could have alien vs. Terminator it could
happen and fun fact
Lance Henriksen Bill Paxton and mr. bean
are all featured in both movies big mr.
bean I met Michael Biehn but shout out
to mr. bean Sarah Connor scores major
points for helping save our future and
stopping the more imminent threat to our
planet terminator but Ellen Ripley had
to go to the far reaches of space to
face an entire plot of incomprehensibly
twisted miracles of evolution and no one
could even hear her scream it's heroic
to fight baddies from a comfort of your
own planet its next level to play an
away game and do it behind enemy lines
ellen has the most frequent flier miles
and she wins my tiebreaker Congrats to
Ripley
say hi to Newt for me or don't I was
never that big a fan upper or children
in general that's just my opinion
dear interweb now it's your turn to vote
and tell us who is the most badass in
your ride is it Sarah Connor or is it
Ellen Ripley to cast your ballot simply
comment below with your take and defend
your answer like the future of humanity
depends on it thanks for watching today
and remember whether you watch us on
desktop laptop or smartphone hug your
device tell it you love it and will do
its bidding once Skynet goes online I'm
Mark Ellis now get away from her you
[ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]